good morning believe nation today's
message is execute your ideas over to
you Robin Sharma I mean the reality is
reading a book or going to a conference
or having a great conversation where you
get this golden information that's all
fantastic but what makes mastery is
execution on the ideas not the ideas and
so no idea works unless you're willing
to roll up your sleeves do the practice
invest the time put in the effort do the
work I think we've all observed a lot of
people who they love reading the books
they love showing up at the courses they
do all the online training and nothing
ever changes and they say well you know
I don't know why it doesn't change why
my life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger to practice one thing that
makes them great is they are willing to
sacrifice I mean yes they're passionate
but did you know the root of the word
passion is suffering you've got to be
willing to suffer for your vision you've
got to be willing to suffer to reach BIW
best in world you've got to be willing
to suffer the ridicule and laughter of
your critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class so what do you
think I agree and I'm gonna add an extra
spin on it execution obviously super
important I feel like everyone can
realize nothing would get done in the
world unless people execute on ideas I
think more important is that you find an
idea that compels execution you have a
million ideas a day but some of them
don't stick they're not that great you
don't you're not compelled to X
cute on them the idea itself should be
inspiring and motivating and passionate
enough to get you executing and if it's
not it's probably not a fit for you as
an idea Jenner eyes going deep on that
one I like it I think about my youtube
channel because of how you guys are
watching and you know YouTube's goal
let's try to keep you on YouTube as long
as possible
watch time was the biggest metric and
you know if I keep you on YouTube as
long as possible might be does get
rewarded and I'll get more search
traffic and while I love that you guys
are watching the videos my goal isn't to
keep you on my channel all day long
right like I need you out there doing
stuff you get an idea you get
inspiration you get something from one
of these videos I want you to go and
actually take action right it's easy
just to watch your video and get
inspired the hard thing is actually
doing and so I just came back from
Chicago I was at Sage Summit and I did
two presentations there and you know
everybody's all riled up and excited and
I'm so motivated now you see the tweets
and all the post coming in but the real
test is do you go home and actually do
something about it because it's easy to
get motivated watching a video or going
to a conference but then it's easy to
then fall back into your regular
patterns and the fear kicks in and the
self-doubt kicks in and all that other
stuff kicks in to prevent you from going
off and actually doing your thing so
when you get that idea when you get that
motivation you get inspired for me I
think it's taking immediate action like
you watch something on my channel or
somebody else's channel take immediate
action even if it's the smallest thing
to get the ball moving because if you
wait till tomorrow even though it
logically makes sense yeah tomorrow I'll
do it you're gonna wake up and you
probably won't do it tomorrow
and you put it off to the next day and
the next you wake up and you probably
even totally forget about it and so when
you get those ideas take some kind of
immediate execution towards fulfilling
that idea so the question today today is
what idea
are you executing now leave in the
comments below we will join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go